if there a relationship between the
phases vertices and edges of a straight
face solid every straight face solid has
faces vertices and edges take the
example of a cube this is how it's
three-dimensional view looks like we
need to find a number of faces the
number of vertices and a number of edges
in a cube let's count the number of
faces first it has six faces in all top
and bottom front and back left and right
we write at six here how many vertices
does it have core at the top and four at
the bottom eight and all and how many
edges pause the video and write the
number of edges here let's count four
horizontal ones at the top four vertical
ones in the middle and four horizontal
ones at the bottom 12 edges in total now
here's the important question is there a
relation between these three parameters
of a straight face solid the answer is
yes for any straight face solid if we
add its number of faces to its number of
vertices and then subtract the number of
edges we get one special number and that
number is two for a cube 6 plus 8 minus
12 gives us 2 and this holds true for
any straight face solid which are the
other straight face solids we know of
cuboid is 1 it looks like this a pube is
nothing but a special case of a cuboid
where the length breadth and the height
are equal so a cuboid also has 6 faces 8
vertices and 12 edges and f+ we - e will
give us 2 let's see if it works for
other straight faced solids do you
remember what a square pyramid looks
like it is a figure with a square as its
base and triangles as its faces square
base and 4 triangles as faces and what
is a triangular prism a prism is a 3
solid which has identical and parallel
ends and also at faces a triangular
prism would look like this it has two
identical and parallel triangles at its
ends and three rectangular faces what do
we need to find out here we need to find
the number of faces the number of
vertices and the number of edges in each
of the solids and see if F plus V minus
e will give us two
okay let's tackle the first solid a
square pyramid how many faces do you see
there are four triangular faces and one
square face five in all how many
vertices one at the top at for Echo Base
five vertices and how many edges for
slant edges and four edges at the base a
total of eight edges we got F V and E as
5 5 and 8 respectively and 5 plus 5
minus 8 will give us 2 so it worked for
the square pyramid 2's plus we - e gave
us 2 this is called Euler's formula for
any straight face solid f plus V minus E
will always give us 2 will Oilers
formula work for the triangular prism -
why don't you give it a try
okay so how many faces do triangular
faces at the ends and three rectangular
faces in between five faces how many
vertices three at this end and three at
the other six vertices three edges at
the front face three in between and
three at the back face nine HSN all what
will be 5 plus 6 minus 9 guess we get a
2 we will always get a - that's Euler's
formula s plus V minus E will always
give us a tune
[Music]